-Thank you very much, everybody.
Welcome.
Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, it's been
a pretty epic 24 hours.
Joe Biden was certified
as our next president.
Several --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Several staffers have resigned
from the White House.
Trump's social media accounts
were banned.
And yet, compared to yesterday,
it's a slow news day.
[ Laughter ]
I'm still trying to
process everything.
Did anyone else have a tough
time calming down last night?
It wasn't easy falling asleep.
I tried listening
to my mediation app,
but the guy leading the session
was just chanting,
"25th Amendment,
25th Amendment."
[ Laughter ]
Honestly, don't you just wish
we could go back to
the good old days,
where all we had to worry about
was a global pandemic
and murder hornets?
2021 feels like the end
of a "Scooby-Doo" episode
where we pull off its mask
to reveal
it's been 2020 all along.
It's like...
[ Laughter ]
God, I miss 2020.
Things are so crazy.
Today, Mexico was like, "If you
need a wall around your Capitol,
we'll pay for it."
Meanwhile,
some of the rioters claimed
they didn't realize
that they were trespassing.
Sadly, not many people
were charged
because the police said
it was "all white."
[ Audience groans ]
I think if there's anything
to be learned from yesterday,
it's that Merrick Garland
can't have one fun day.
I mean, first, his Supreme Court
nomination gets blocked,
then he gets a new job,
and a riot happens.
Seriously, what did this guy do
in a previous life,
kick over strollers?
Anyway, late last night,
Congress reconvened
and completed the certification
of the Electoral College votes.
[ Applause ]
Yeah.
And all jokes aside,
I thought it was so cool
that Congress came back
and didn't let those losers win.
I thought it was a pretty
powerful message to send.
But because of all the chaos,
Pence officially affirmed
Biden's victory
at 3:45 in the morning.
Yep.
After the win was certified,
Biden was like, "Gee, thanks.
Can't wait to take over
this paradise."
[ Laughter ]
That's right, Congress
worked through the night
and confirmed Biden's victory
around 4:00 a.m.
Yeah, we recognized the election
of the world's
most powerful person
when cable channels
were showing infomercials.
Pence was like, "I hereby
declare Joe Biden as the winner.
And now, stay tuned
for an infomercial
for Marie Osmond's BodyGym."
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
"You don't even feel like
you're sweating."
Today, for the first time,
President Trump
finally acknowledged
that there will be an
orderly transition of power
on January 20th.
When Trump says there will be
an orderly transition,
he means an orderly
is gonna have to drag him
out the front door.
[ Laughter, applause ]
"Get him out of here!"
The reason one of Trump's aides
tweeted that message for him
is because
the President was banned
from all of
his social media accounts,
including Twitter, Facebook,
Instagram, and even Snapchat.
In other news, guess who doesn't
want to ban TikTok anymore?
[ Laughter ]
Love TikTok.
Without Twitter, it was pretty
embarrassing for Trump.
He was walking around
the West Wing
with a piece of paper
and a heart stamp,
yelling, "Like this!
Like this! Like this!
Like this! Like this!"
Since yesterday's riot,
resignations have poured in
at the White House,
and sources expect
they'll keep coming.
Although, resigning
with two weeks left
feels less like some moral stand
and more like leaving early
to beat traffic.
[ Laughter ]
My question is, how do you
put in your two weeks' notice
when your job ends
in less than two weeks?
I read that, according to
his closest allies,
Trump is, quote,
"mentally unreachable,"
while another source believes
the President
is "out of his mind."
If any more news from 2016
breaks throughout the night,
we'll be sure to
keep you updated.
How do you look at four years
of Trump and just now are like,
"I'm starting to think
this guy is nuts"?
[ Laughter ]
"You guys catching a vibe?"
Today, both Chuck Schumer
and Nancy Pelosi
called for Pence
to pursue the 25th Amendment
and remove Trump from office.
If that happened, we'd have
three presidents in 13 days.
I love the idea of changing
presidents like movie Batmans.
[ Laughter ]
Let's get to some lighter news.
I saw that Discovery
has confirmed
the "Puppy Bowl" will go on
as scheduled this year.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Phew," said absolutely no one.
The "Puppy" --
The "Puppy Bowl"
is the one event
that brings every American
together to think, "Why?"
And finally, in New Jersey,
police responded to
a McDonald's parking lot,
where chickens
were chasing customers
and wreaking havoc.
I think this explains why today
Trump released a message
saying, "I love you chickens,
but it's time to go home."